unhelpful advice with bobby kleiner and
stevie weeby
bonjour my name is brandon i'm a 23 year
old and i live in central washington i
think my new my new roommate wants to
have sex with me i just moved back from
thailand after living there for eight
months and i found a place with an old
cold co-worker the guy that owns the
house is in his mid-40s and saying he is
not entertaining is an understatement
every time i'm in the kitchen he will
come out from the basement wearing his
pajamas and every time he has a massive
boner
he once told me that he'd rather pay his
boys to keep him company rather than a
female sex worker what do i do thanks
wait wait is this person
i think it's so it's a 23 23 year old
male 1 he has a new roommate who's a 40
year old man
uh and he you [ __ ] move
no what's so wrong with just saying hey
dude put your dick away man
because you don't want that when you're
making a grilled cheese sandwich at like
one in the morning i don't want to see
your [ __ ] roommate's dick they just
say dude put your dick away yeah but
just the thought that he could be
jerking off in the other room and
thinking about you is
right yeah steve you have a new roommate
he's a 40 year old uh he's a 58 year old
comes out with a bulge massive [ __ ]
walks out we would have a talk he hears
you make it right
he's a 40 year old guy i'm the
four-year-old guy all right so just all
right you're making a sandwich listen
troy no no let me i'll come up to you
first i'll be troy yeah hey can you make
me a sandwich listen man
yeah
you can't be doing that around here
i own this house what do you mean you
live in my house
it's just uh inappropriate you're making
me uncomfortable okay but what all i'm
asking is to clothe yourself man i know
i have my pajamas on and i see your
penis protruding no it's like yeah but
my pants i can't help that i have a
heart on right now when i look at you
it makes me uncomfortable i'm just
letting you know that looking at you
makes me feel uncomfortable because i
just want a nut in your mouth yeah but i
can't do it legally because i don't want
to know we have a severe problem we
don't have it because i'm never going to
die in your mouth
but it doesn't matter you're making me
very uncomfortable and if you don't do
anything about i'm moving out okay or
you're not going to have to all right
i'm going to go change i'm going to go
change thank you i come back with jeans
all right i'll come back with you
stronger still making me that sandwich
i'll make you a grilled cheese sandwich
but yeah just yeah my jeans yeah i have
my jeans you see i'm wearing my um all
right we're good my hunting jacket
right hunting
i have a hunting jacket on and my jeans
we're good but can i let you know right
now yeah i still have a hard one
[Music]
see i i have a problem with that i have
a problem with that i hope you cannot
have a problem with
[Music]
can't i live with you man i know please
so right now i have a parking lot
all right i'll pay my rent i have a
parker on right i have all this stuff on
yeah right can you still make me the
sandwich i'll make you a sandwich right
just i don't hey hey steve yeah please
don't say anything derogatory i'm not
saying
i'm gonna let you know right now that
way i'm gonna let you know right now i
don't have a heart on
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
do you joke off still every night
you know what i was i was standing for
months you know that yeah i know you
were doing good for like two three
months you were doing good i followed it
brother
there was this weird korean mall
and there's this coffee shop there that
obviously they have in the mall in the
in the basement
where they have they make they have you
know on a paper thing we make you know
what i mean fish waffles yeah like fish
waffles right
so my brother and
let's get some let's get some and then
they toiled
explain what that means
it's a whole to do in their faces that
when they go
oh
so they had they go get the batter
they have to mix it right
it's their attitude right like i don't
want it i don't want to be doing this
but like no one ever orders this right
yeah it was like a total toil
so it you know and you're as a customer
you're watching them go through all
these motions it happens in the service
industry
you and i will always laugh at services
and stuff
and then because we've worked they
finally it took 20 minutes oh she had to
get on the ladder yeah get on a little
ladder yeah and pour
we grab it we take a bite into it it's
terrible we throw it away we throw it
away but then we decided to
we walked out of the ball and then we
had a meeting and they go we go we
should order more
yeah
so we go back and like
just so that she'd have to go through
this process again
again and another thing we did hold up
yeah okay so the other one was you know
how like like there's el pollo locos but
then some of them have like fr uh
foster's friends no was that wendy's
wendy's and they have a frost those
wendy's to get a frosty yeah same thing
they toiled yeah right
with this one they did this soft serve
and it was dripping on their hands yeah
they hated it and you could tell they
didn't like it
so we we took a bite we threw it away we
got back in the line and we kept
ordering it
[Laughter]
but here's
what here's
here's what i did
with kalila what'd you do and if i was
with you what would happen you and i
would be dying laughing whatever but
with her i didn't have that moment oh
okay it was a fight what happened so
there's
we were in
one of the islands in hawaii and we're
at a hotel called the prince yeah and
they have this
long kind of um
colder sack driveway in front of the
right where you go in a circle in front
of the hotel right like it's very long
for the valet right right so i got in
the car
so when you go around you can just go
onto the main street yeah or you can go
continue in the circle
right yeah so i picked up the car
and i go she goes where you go i go i
gotta wave to the guys to the valet yeah
so we went by the valet and i went
right yeah and the valley they weigh
right yeah
i did it
12 more times
but but by the fourth time glenn is
screaming at me
by the tent that when i'm waving they're
just kind of looking at me like i'm on
drugs but i just keep going around
but if
but if you're with me if you're well i
would have said it a hundred times we
would have been we would have done it we
would have done it a hundred times and
we've been laughing so [ __ ] hard we
fight the ridiculousness good behavior
it's so it's so funny to me so other
people don't think that's fine no but
you and i find it to be ridiculously
funny and they watch a bad friend and
they were actually there to see tim
dillon
so i go um
oh you like tim too yeah can i take pho
we take photos i go yeah and then they
pulled me and they go
we're really hooked on scissor brothers
and i go
what he's like yeah i think he goes we
think that that guy that has legs
yeah
you're lying i am
oh
wait
we're looking at each other like we had
a breakthrough i don't feel good
why did you do that can i just say this
though
wow this was what you were warning me
about steve what that hurt me so
i'm sorry just hey go
pain
is just running through my veins my
friend are you angry oh just so sad
guess what this guess what's up so sad
guess what though what after this if you
guys want i'll take it to dinner
really
yeah you know what he also does i've
noticed in san diego i mean when we were
in phoenix
when i go hey i'll go call del taco see
if they're open yeah and when he calls
people
he goes like this
he um
he changes his voice i don't know why i
do yeah um are you guys still open
yeah okay cool thank you then i don't
know who you are why doesn't i know but
why does he do that i don't know it's a
weird thing times i'd have to call it so
weird i don't know and i make them call
places just to hear
him
oh excuse me
why do you do that
that's for a future thing yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] crazy i don't know why i do that
you're self-conscious yeah yeah it's
weird it's weird it's really weird say
that again george
do you say this
s-t-e-e-b-e spell your
but next time pick a longer handle why
did you do that pick the longest handle
possible please what if it was so
difficult for people you could even say
your own show name yeah yeah stevie
weeby
[Music]
[Laughter]
i went there with spade and um tim
dillon yeah and um it was just i just
needed to go just to get my juices
flowing i'm scared of it
i've never done it in a while
yeah i'm scared of it are you
rusty yeah i'm rusty you are i don't
know what i'm you know i'm scared to do
it you're scared to do it so it's like
your open mic again
yeah i i feel like it no well settle
down
i want to see mom yeah come on oh you do
yeah okay good i text her every day i do
too every day because she texts you
first right absolutely she does these
long
i love the inspirational inspirational
questions it's weird does she send the
emojis or bitmojis over no quotes
inspiration she does like she'll have
like it'll be like
um
a photograph of a butterfly
yeah and i'll say you know today is the
only day that we have live in the moment
and they'll be using this butterfly oh
yeah yeah
i love it and then i don't know what to
text me so i'm like i never heard that
before
[Laughter]
heart emoji
what
heart emoji you send a heart emoji every
day that's all you put you don't believe
me i say i i do three or four i go i
love you mom one day yeah i love you
where's your phone i'm i'm gonna read
you what i've let's see if they're
similar okay no i did say the same stuff
yeah yeah yeah i'm because i'm very
similar on mine too so let's do this
right so
i'm gonna where's my mom where's mom mom
okay so
so here here's mine right and these are
like yours all right so
so she goes um well i'll you read three
or four i'll read three or four just you
want to do responses
here's my response okay three or four
good night and dream beautiful dreams no
read hers first or uh yeah to give
context uh all right yeah yeah okay okay
sorry
you are here for a reason there's
nothing accidental about you there's a
specific purpose assignment and mission
on earth that only you can fulfill never
doubt your specialness
then i go good night and
three beautiful dreams
that's better than mine
what is your okay at cigna pharmacy i
picked up some medication and on the way
home i stopped at albertson's and got
some groceries yeah good night
exclamation point
wishing you a peaceful night's rest
that's your response no and then my
response is you too oma
[Laughter]
all right all right i'll give you the
one okay so this is my mother mom she
does a dr seuss okay she goes why fit in
when you were born to stand out dr seuss
then she says stay safe and healthy good
night and sweet dreams love you and then
my response is that's a good quote mom
hope everything is okay
ask if you need something
you're doing way better than me good go
give me here give me um
time to go to bed
stay safe and take care
good night and sleep tight love you
in my response
night mom
heart
that's all the um
do two more and then we'll wrap it up
we'll wrap it up i'll do one more i'll
just do one more i'll wrap it up all
right
93 degrees this is what she says 93
degrees right now i think the summer is
around the corner good night and sleep
tight hope you're feeling good miss you
so much i love you with all my heart
you're killing me
yeah go ahead um
it's windy outside but the temperature
is perfect today
take care and stay safe good night and
sleep tight love you
what's your response
i love you
sorry
i did a repeat s t
e e
b
why'd you do it so hard i don't know
spelling bee style your mom texted me
too
go ahead jeremy
she said at the end of hardship comes
happiness and it's a picture of a yak
and then it says is steve vaccinated yet
yeah yeah i knew i'm sorry i'm sorry
you're like
you're the gayest non-gay guy i've ever
met myself i don't i'll take that it
really i when i when i first met you i'm
like who was that [ __ ] probably heard
the story 20 times again
yeah and then it's so weird that you eat
[ __ ]
yeah it's so weird
dear heavenly father
thank thank you for uh blessing us today
and uh allowing me to see my brother
i am going to get vaccinated soon are
you really gonna yeah i am i i know you
know who you are
yeah my friend my friend eric is working
on it as we speak we're waiting
wait eric
wait
eric works at a clinic he knows someone
at a clinic right you but you could just
anyway okay so this is my prayer though
yeah all right
prayer this is my prayer yours thank you
um thank you for allowing jeremiah to be
here today rudy thank you tito bobby
thank you for like
uh allowing us to start scissor bros
podcast together yeah uh and thank you
for our health and that we're allowed to
podcast during
these times these times thank you for
allowing us to have food in our systems
every day
yeah and our bodily systems
yeah we need new nutrients
and thank you for the sun light
whoa
that you know a lot of people don't ever
think the sun
oh yeah yeah yeah without the sun what
happens you die
maybe i go uh brady
open the window to todd's house and
we'll steal his weed
so he
broke this
window oh yeah he broke it i snuck into
the little space
i stole his weed and then what we did
was we put it in my car hid in my car
and we waited todd to get home and when
he got home we rang his doorbell
and he goes like okay can we buy some
weed he goes someone broke into our
house
my house and stole the weed and we and
we helped him look for the guy oh my god
you're one of those
we're helping look who did that
right and so
for hours him and i we went down the
streets looking for cars we know we have
a piece of [ __ ] yeah but i'm um i'm one
of those drug addicts you know that
there's a there's that one kid who
easily i love you so much
[Music]
[Music]
you